so here's the question we want to answer
today why can't we kill a virus okay
well it's because viruses are not alive
in the first place
they're a piece of genetic material very
mysterious wrapped in a sack and they
invade our body they go into our cells
and they latch on to the machinery of
our cells usually the DNA and they start
to use our own body's energy to
replicate so you really can't kill a
virus because it doesn't really have a
life force but you can definitely
acquire a virus get sick and then once
your body deals with that virus it
doesn't necessarily kill it again
because it's no live it goes into
remission it goes in a dormant stage and
that's called a latent virus and that's
what I want to talk about so many of you
watching probably had a virus infection
in the past that virus is still in your
body it might come out as herpes like in
a canker sore in your mouth or a cold
sore in your mouth type one herpes is in
the mouth of the tongue type twos and
the genitals and it really tends to hang
out and the nerves so here you have this
infection your immune system deals with
it it goes into remission and it's a
cyst there and it waits and it waits and
it waits until you're rundown you're
stressed out and you're tired and you're
sick and you're nutritionally deficient
and then it comes out and gets
reactivated you have epstein-barr virus
a lot of people have that as a teenager
that can be reactivated later in life
from stress and you may not necessarily
even pull on the full infection it could
just make you chronically fatigued
because you're going through a stress
event what not chemotherapy can activate
epstein-barr virus radiation can
activate epstein-barr virus then you
have human papilloma virus 90% of the
population has this virus in their body
and that can be reactivated through
stress and when I talk about stress it
could be mental stress it can
be a loss it could be physical stress
then you have another virus called the
cytomegalovirus which can be reactivated
if it's in a dormant stage from
inflammation this is why if you have
colitis or inflammation of your colon
that can reactivate this virus now the
problem with this virus it can lead to
cervical cancer
chicken pox virus can be reactivated and
as herpes zoster or shingles so you can
see a lot of viruses just sitting there
as a potential problem but you're gonna
be fine
as long as you don't ever experience
stress anymore or nutritional
deficiencies then you're gonna be good
to go I just want to talk about three
really important nutrients that help
suppress viruses these are the three
nutrients that are probably the most
antiviral of any of the nutrients out
there and vitamin D is the top of the
list
now the microbes in TB which is a
bacteria and this is a virus
epstein-barr virus and the HIV virus
what they do they have a strategy they
decrease the receptor for your vitamin D
called the vitamin D receptor in other
words if this is the receptor right here
for vitamin D they will somehow block
this so you don't get vitamin D so
you're gonna be vitamin D deficient and
then these things will survive this is
kind of a survival mechanism by these
pathogens right here so if you have
these infections okay it's very
important to have enough vitamin D and
I've done tons of videos on this I put
some links down below it's very
difficult to get vitamin D from the diet
and it's very difficult to get vitamin D
from the Sun if it's the wintertime so
it's important to make sure you get
enough also vitamin D decreases the risk
of cervical cancer okay I talked about
that right here and the reason for that
is that vitamin D helps suppress the
virus that can trigger the cancer you go
back here
vitamin D can also decrease the risk of
influenza the flu virus okay and also
respiratory infections it can help
protect you in almost bulletproof
yourself against respiratory infections
zinc is the next most important mineral
to talk about in relationship to viruses
because it can decrease the frequency of
that virus getting reactivated the
duration of the time that it is in
activation and it can also decrease the
severity of the symptoms especially with
herpes and shingles which is along the
nerve roots and if you have shingles
it's very important to also take a sink
oxide topically you can put it right of
lesions and really decrease the pain and
the third one is selenium very very
important if you're deficient you you
get a lot more viral reactivation than
if you had enough alright thanks for
watching if you're liking this content
please subscribe now and I will actually
keep you updated on future videos